la justice ne répond à aucune des
questions importantes dans cette affaire
c'est tout on sait simplement que Sylvie
Reviriego a tué d'une façon atroce celle
qui avait été son
[Musique]
ami
Sylvie revirego en 1988 la presse l'a
surnommé la dépesseuse de tour parce
qu'elle avait tué sa meilleure amie et
tenté de faire disparaître son corps en
le découp sur son balcon et en mettant
sa tête dans un four
elle va s'attacher à détruire la tête
elle va effectivement s'acharner sur un
cadavre pourquoi Sylvie revierego
a-t-elle basculé dans l'horreur
elle était mère de deux enfants elle
avait un travail elle avait passé des
examens pour être exoignante elle était
bien intégrée dans la
société pour la défense c'est son
traitement amincissant qui l' conduite à
la psychose et à commettre ce crime une
explication inédite à
l'époque je pense que la justice est
passé à côté de la vérité 30 ans plus
tard les mêmes interrogations demeurent
il peut y avoir dans cette affaire une
terrible erreur judiciaire
avecali nous avons décidé de retrouver
les protagonistes de cette affaire et
d'analyser avec eux les conséquences et
les répercussions de ce dossier hors
norme
19h45 le verdict tombe sylvie revirego
est condamné à la prison à perpétuité le
jury de la cour d'assise d'indrloir ne
lui a reconnu aucune circonstance
atténuante pour le meurtre de Françoise
Gendron tout commence le 13 décembre
1988 des agents d'entretien découvrent
deux sacs pouBell sur le parking de
l'hôpital de tour
[Musique]
à l'intérieur des morceaux de corps
humain on a cru que c'était des des
Carabins des des étudiants en médecine
qui avaient fait une farce voilà et donc
on découvre d'abord le tronin et
quelques jours après les membres sur une
zone commerciale de chambré c'està-dire
pas très loin de l'hôpital Trousseau à
un ou 2
km un Tron des membres mais pas de tête
difficile donc d'identifier ce corps
sans visage tout ce que l'on sait c'est
qu'il s'agit d'une
femme les recherches dans le fichier des
empreintes digitales créé l'année
précédente en
1987 ne donneent rien les policiers
décident alors de passer un appel à
témoins dans le journal local les
policiers m'ont demander de mettre un
détail dans le papier que j'allais
écrire c'était une m cause dans le dos
de la vie victime et le matin où le mon
article est passé il y a eu trois coups
de téléphone anonyme à la PJ disant
voilà la victime c'est Françoise
Gendron Françoise Gendron une mère
divorcée de 38
ans les policiers se rendent chez
elles
personne les voisins affirment qu'ils ne
l'ont pas vu depuis plusieurs jours
quant à ses proches ils n'en savent pas
plus son unique fils Cyril fait son
service militaire loin de tour il y a
bien un homme dans la vie de Françoise
mais lui aussi est sans nouvelle il n'a
eu qu'un coup de fil d'une de ses amis
qui lui annonçait que Françoise partait
en
vacances cet ami c'est Sylvie reviriegoo
aide soignante à l'hôpital de tour les
deux femmes se connaissent depuis
l'enfance et font partie depuis quelques
temps d'une même petite bande d'amis
ces personnes se fréquentaient dans une
discothèque de tour où il y avait un
étage pour les cadragénir en recherche
de
contact dans ce petit groupe de fitard
il y avait deux hommes mais l'enquête
l'aimit rapid Mor de
cause reste alors syv
virego les policiers perquisitionnent
son appartement à l'intérieur d'étranges
petites taches brunes autour de la
baignoire les enquêteurs trouvent aussi
des bijoux appartenant à
[Musique]
Françoise sylvie revirigo est placé en
garde à vue après quelques heures
d'interrogatoire
elle
craque elle a dit bon je vous je
n'arrête pas de vous mentir bon
finalement c'est moi qui est
tué Sylvie revirego raconte en détail ce
lundi 12 décembre 1988
elle est d'abord allée chez Françoise
pour tenter de la tuer en jetant un
sèchecheveux dans son
bain mais son projet d'électrocution n'a
pas
fonctionné alors elle a invité son ami
dans son propre appartement là elle lui
a offert un thé bourré
d'anxiolitique
Sylvie entraîne Françoise vers la salle
de bain lui fait reprendre à nouveau un
bravage et sous prétexte de lui faire du
bien lui dit qu'il va prendre un bain et
donc la mène jusqu'à la
baignoire Sylvie revirigo maintient la
tête de son ami sous l'eau un long
moment puis elle lui tranche les veines
jusqu'à ce que Françoise se vide de son
sang
elle fait couler l'eau pour que le sang
parte donc lorsque le le sang le sang
est vidé donc elle elle
retire avec sans doute beaucoup de
difficultés le corps elle essaie de le
découper le dépaissage s'avère plus
difficile que
prévu les enfants de Sylvie ne vont pas
tarder à rentrer de l'école elle
enveloppe la dépouille de son ami dans
un tapis et la cache sur le le balcon de
sa
chambre l'extraordinaire se passe après
et avec une organisation qui pose
question parce que ses enfants
revenaient manger elle cachaient le
cadavre elle leur faisait à manger quand
ils étaient partis ressortit le cadavre
et ça dure 3
jours Sylvie Reviriego organise même une
petite fête pour les 14 ans de son fils
une fête prévue de longue date la soirée
se passe bien personne ne se doute de
rien à peine se souviendra-t-on d'une
petite phrase lâchée par Sylvie à une
invitée je me suis mise dans une drôle
de galère siôt la soirée terminée Sylvie
reviregoo se remett à la
tâche le lendemain les enfants repartent
à l'école et là donc elle coupe la tête
elle donc détache la tête du corps et
nous dit-elle elle la met sous un saut
pour ne pas la voir
[Musique]
l'aide soignante a l'impression que
cette tête la nargue elle ne sait plus
quoi en
faire dans un premier temps elle
s'occupe des autres morceaux du cadavre
qu'elle réparti dans des sacs pouBell
avant de s'en débarrasser sur le parking
de l'hôpital où elle
travaille il reste la tête et tous les
soirs TR soirs elle va donc s'attacher à
détruire la tête
elle arrive à tirer gérer les les
partières molles elle en jette nous
dit-elle dans les dans les WC ainsi que
les dents des dents seront trouvées mais
elle n'arrive pas à détruire le le crâne
et le 2è le deuxè soir elle comme elle
n'y arrive pas elle elle dans ses aveux
elle n
dit j'ai décidé de la mettre au four et
la faire cuire à
350° revg aurait mis la tête de son ami
dans son four en position pyrolise les
policiers pennent à y
croire pour preuve elle les conduit sur
le pont de Chinon là où elle a jeté les
morceaux de crâne
restants la chance a voulu que à
l'endroit où ils ont été jetés il y
avait un banc de sable où le courant ne
passait pas réellement de sorte que les
sapeurs pompiers dont qui sont
intervenus ont retrouvé ben les eau dans
un périmètre très très restreint et
c'est ainsi que pratiquement tout le
crâne a pu êtreonstitué à part quelques
quelques parties qui avaent été jeté
préalablement
mais une expertise a été faite bien sûr
et qui a confirmé ce que ce à quoi nous
ne croyons pas au début savoir que le
crâne avait effectivement été porté à
haute
température
[Musique]
je Jean-Michel cluski vous êtes l'avocat
du fils de François jendron Cyril
comment apprend-il ce qui est arrivé à
sa mère je vois arriver un garçon qui
est une boule de haine et je vais être
confronté au problème de lui expliquer
ce qui s'est passé et quand on sait la
manre dont les choses se sont passées le
sort qui a été réservé à sa mère on peut
pas lui balancer en bloc tout ce qui
s'est passé elle était sa seule famille
alors oui parce que il n'a pas de père
ni frère ni sœur ni grands-parents il a
personne d'autre si vous vouz il va y
avoir un phénomène j'ai l'âge d'être son
père et et je vais me rendre compte
assez rapidement qu'il y a un transfert
une confiance qui qui qui se gagne et il
va être entre guillemets assez obéissant
il connaissait Sylvie reverego oh il
avait av d la voir quelquefis j'ai pas
le souvenir qu'il en pensait grandchose
d'ailleurs vous dire Sylv revg on a
entendu un certain nombre de témoins
c'était une femme qui n'avait qui
n'attirait pas particulièrement
l'antipathie alors une seule question se
pose
pourquoi pourquoi Sylvie revirego s'en
est-elle prise à son ami avec tant de
hargne
elle reprochait à François jendron
d'avoir une vie trop dissolue ça ça
paraît complètement démesuré par rapport
au fait qu'on tue
quelqu'un tellement démesuré que la
justice fait tout pour comprendre deux
experts psychiatres sont nommés pour
examiner Sylvie
revierego Martin vous rencontrez Sylvie
reveriegoo le lendemain de ses aveux à
la maison d'arrêt d'Orléan comment est
cette
femme nous nous attendions à trouver
devant nous une malade mentale et on a
était surpris de la qualité de son de
son de son récit et de la de sa lucidité
elle décrivait les choses quand même
sans sans aucune
culpabilité sans aucun remord que vous
dit Sylvie reveriegoo de ses relations
avec Françoise Gendron c'était la copine
qui dirigeait tout en quelque sorte et
elle se sentait toujours infériorisée
quand même donc François Gendron lui
laissaer les hommes qu'elle ne voulait
pas en plus lui emprunter de l'argent
alors les hommes l'argent se sentant
infériorisé parce que elle restait
toujours en retrait ça a créé une
tension entre elle avec le temps c'est
devenu aussi de la haine à la fin de
cette première rencontre quelles sont
vos
conclusions qu'il s'agit d'une femme
lucide
responsable qui ne présente aucune
pathologie
mentale pour les psychiatres Sylvie
revirgo ne relève donc pas de l'article
64 du Code pénal un article selon lequel
il n'y a ni crime ni délit si l'accusé
est en état de démence au moment des
faits ou lorsqu'il est été contraint par
une force à laquelle il n'a pas pu
résister
dans ces cas-là l'accusé n'est pas jugé
au lieu de la prison on l'enferme dans
un hôpital psychiatrique pour le
soigner est-ce que vous allez revoir
Sylvie revirego pour confirmer ses
premières impressions nous l'avons
revu cinq fois après ce premier
entretien donc six fois au total et la
deuxième fois nous avons été très
surpris du fait qu'il y avait une
amnésie totale elle reconnaissait à
peine les experts aussi connaissait plus
elle ne reconnaissait plus une amnésie à
laquelle les psychiatres ne croient pas
tellement l'accusé leur a décrit avec
force détails les faits et la scène de
crime quant à la partie civile elle ne
veut pas en entendre parler votre client
Cyril Gendron et vous vous y croyez à
cette histoire d'amnésie
pas une seconde alors lui n'y croit pas
parce qu'il a pas envie du tout de
croire à quoi que ce soit qui vienne
atténuer la responsabilité de cette
criminelle euh moi je n'y crois pas pour
d'autres raisons c'est-à-dire il se
trouve que j'ai à ce moment-là aussi
d'autres clientes incarcéré et que je
sais pertinemment que pendant qu'elle
raconte à la justice qu'elle a oublié
tout ce qui s'est passé elle raconte à
ses camarades à la à la maison d'arrêt
par le détail ce qui s'est passé
autrement dit cette amnésie était
bienvenu j'ai connu des cas où ce qu'on
ce que les experts appellent l'amnésie
salvatrice c'estàdire que quand quand on
a effectivement commis des actes qui
sont épouvantables il y a un travail de
mémoire qui est qui est phénoménal et
qui finit par gommer effectivement ce
qu'on a commis là c'était pas ça du tout
c'était à mon sens un moyen de
défense une défense qui a pourtant des
arguments qui pourrait expliquer non
seulement l'amnésie mais aussi le
passage à l'acte car depuis quelques
mois Sylvie revirego n'était plus tout à
fait la même la vie de Sylvie a été
quand même bousculée lque que bon elle a
appris que son mari l'avait trompé et a
priori elle n'a pas supporté et donc
elle a décidé de quitter son mari et est
parti s'installer avec ses deux enfants
donc à tour et c'est à tour où elle
retrouve Françoise Françoise qui dans
l'intervalle a mené une vie elle
différente bon une vie faite de liberté
de petit boulot elle a eu un fils bon
elle n'est elle n'est pas mariée et elle
a l'habitude de de sortir de sortir en
boî d'aller en boîte de bah de profiter
de la
[Musique]
vie maître lisoncrose vous êtes
l'avocate de Sylvie reviregoo en 1988
c'est quelqu'un qui est mal dans sa peau
elle vient divorcer
elle se trouve trop grosse et elle va
voir un un médecin qui va lui prescrire
un certain nombre de de
médicaments pour la faire
migrir elle a perdu 15 17 kg je crois
Sylvie revirgou en 5 mois de temps 17
kg qu'est-ce qu'il lui
prescrit des des
amphétamines des extraits thyroïdes des
benzodiazépines des
dururétiques ah pas dans la même
préparation parce que ça c'est interdit
par la loi la loi talon de 1980
mais ça se retrouve sur la même
ordonnance et dans l'estomac de Sylvie
revirgo bah tout ça se
mélange ce traitement maître ça pourrait
expliquer le
crime écoutz un un un
crime pour le mobile qu'on a voulu lui
prêter à savoir la jalousie qu'elle
aurait nourri envers cette ami d'enfance
qu'elle a retrouvé avec laquelle elle
sortait qu' l'agçait et cetera c'est un
c'est un mobile quand même léger la
prise de ces médicaments pourrait-elle
expliquer l'amnésie dont elle se dit
victime
alors les avis des médicaux ont été
partagés sur le sujet est-ce une amnésie
salvatrice c'est dire on tire le rideau
elle tire le rideau parce que c'est trop
horrible et puis il y a d'autres
médecins qui disent attention elle
prenait des benzos d'aspine
et ça joue sur la mémoire en tout cas
bon il y avait pas de de de manipulation
de mensonge chez elle et vous avez un
test c'est le test
MMPI pratiqué par une psychologue et ils
ont remarqué qu'elle avait la note basse
sur l'échelle du
mensonge Sylvie reviriegoo a-t-elle été
victime de ce cocktail
médicamenteux interrogé les experts
judiciaires sont
catégoriques le médicament n'explique ni
l'amnésie ni le passage à l'acte les
benzodiasépines peuvent provoquer une
amnésie c'est c'est connu mais cette
amnésie s'accompagne de trouble du
comportement habituellement et ne dure
pas alors l'amphétamine crée c'est sûr
une n une certaine nervosité une
certaine tension nerveuse
mais c'est insuffisant
pour expliquer ce passage à l' dans la
mesure où elle prenait l'amphétamine
depuis 6 mois avant l'effet et elle n'a
jamais manifesté de nervosité
particulière il y a eu une surexpertise
avec deux experts
parisiens qui ont conclu comme nous
maître lisoncrose vous contestez les
rapports de ces deux collèges d'experts
pourquoi parce qu'il se trompe et parce
qu'ils
évacuent très rapidement cette psychose
médicamenteuse ils ne l'ont pas vu assez
longtemps il n'y a pas eu de prise de
sang de fête à Sylvie reviriegoo et
cette prise de sang aurait dû être faite
dès le départ j'ai demandé des contes
Expertis
toxyologique je ne les ai pas obtenu
avec mon confrère Jacques léoté on a
voulu faire venir le docteur oler qui
envoyant nos pièces envoyant les six
ordonnances de médicaments pour maigrir
a dit ou là là là là mais c'est pas
[Musique]
possible
Jean-Pierre olier à la lecture du
dossier que pensez-vous de ce cocktail
de médicament l'association amphétamine
et hormone thyroïdienne par exemple
provoqu chez certains animaux des
comportements à type d'assassinat de
leur propre progéniture et donc les
amphétamines sont des substances capabl
chez chacun de nous d'entraîner une
perte d'in i de certains comportements
et de faire nître espèce d'idée fixe par
exemple tuer sa meilleure amie sans
motif et d'autre part les
benzodiazépines qui sont des médicaments
tranquilisants sont aussi capables de
provoquer des troubles du comportement
ce qui semble bizarre dans le cas de
Sylvie revirego c'est que ce qu'on va
appeler sa folie he semble s'installer
et durer plusieurs jours moi je n'ai pas
examiné cette personne mais ce que je
peux dire c'est que quelqu'un qui prend
pendant plusieurs jours ou plusieurs
semaines des substances telles que
celles qu'apparemment elle prenaent
cette personne évidemment va se trouver
dans un état psychotique durable tout au
long de la période pendant laquelle elle
prend les substances toxiques et puis à
côté de ces moments de folie elle semble
mener une vie tout ce qu'il y a de de
plus normal est-ce que ça ça cadre avec
une psychose médicamenteuse avec une
psychose amphétaminique oui absolument
c'est tout à fait typique la personne a
une espèce de de capacité rationnelle
exagérée un contrôle émotionnel tout à
fait singulier une absence d'émotivité
une espèce de froideur et en même temps
une incapacité à véritablement critiquer
l'acte ou les actes qu'elle a commis du
fait de sa
[Musique]
psychose le procès ouvre devant la Cour
d'assise d'indrloire en juin
1991 la défense à 3 jours
pour convaincre les jurés que ce sont
les médicaments qui sont en cause et
tout faire pour éviter à syv rev la
peine
maximale la
[Musique]
perpétuité tour sont en nombre pour
venir assister à l'audience les places
étaient compté les gens faisaient la
queue une ou de heures avant l'ouverture
des
portes
[Musique]
dans quel état d'esprit Cyril jendron le
fils de Françoise se rend-il au procès
oh là là oh là là je peux vous dire que
rien rien n'est apaisé rien n'est apaisé
il va dans l'état d'esprit d'un garçon
qui ne peut imaginer une seconde qu'elle
ne prenne pas le maximum de la peine les
avocats de l'accusé sont tout a décidé
que la partie civile ce qu'il vise c'est
tout bonnement la fin des
poursuites je souhaite une déclaration
de non culpabilité parce qu'elle était
malade qu'elle est toujours malade je
veux qu'elle aille en hôpital
psychiatrique à la barre les experts se
succèdent les psychiatres bien sûr mais
aussi des
pharmacologue la défense tente d'y
opposer des témoins de moralité
les parents de Sylvie revirego ses
collègues de travail tous sont là pour
convaincre la cour qu'elle n'est pas le
monstre qu'on
prétend et j'ai toujours ce
sentiment bien longtemps après que il y
avait un mur en face de nous un mur des
jurés
immobiles un président et des assesseurs
immobiles pas de question des visages
fermés non
[Musique]
vraiment pas il y a pas eu de débat si
vous
voulez on avait l'impression quand même
d'une
justice de notables et de gens entre eux
voilà il y avait cet entre soi des des
des magistrats des experts
judiciaires des policiers enquêteurs
d'une bonne société locale qui qui se
protégeit face à l'horreur absolu que
constitua ce crime et puis on va droit
vers la
condamnation avec
une une extrême bonne conscience fort de
son savoir fort de la puissance de la
justice et puis on y va moi j'ai le
sentiment que la perpétuité ne fait
aucun doute que ce que le procès est
plié d'autant que dans la salle
d'audience un médecin manque à
l'appel celui qui a prescrit à Sylvie
revirg le fameux traitement
6 le Conseil de l'Ordre interdit à ce
médecin généraliste d'exercer pendant 3
mois alors qu'ensuite le médecin
généraliste ne soit pas cité à la barre
comme témoin bah enfin oui c'est
incroyable on aurait franchement on
aurait aimé l'entendre et le voir
interroger le voir s'expliquer comment
se fait-il que ce médecin soit pas au
procès parce que ça c'est je vous dis
encore une fois avec Jacques léé on
avait comme information qu'il était
parti à étranger mais vous demandez à ce
qu'on aille le chercher c'est un procès
d'assise on n pas demandé qu'on aille le
chercher à l'étranger et puis vous
rencontrez un autre obstacle he vous ne
réussissait pas à faire témoigner le
professeur olier au procès le docteur
hlier il avait posé une condition qui se
conçoit tout à fait celle de voir Sylvie
revierig à la maison d'arrêt
préalablement et le procureur de la
République qui était le seulle habilité
à délivrer un permis de communiquer a
refusé au professeur AER ce permis et
donc le professeur olier n'est pas
venu face à ce refus le professeur olier
estime que n'ayant pas pu voir Sylvie
revirg il n'est pas en mesure de
témoigner je refusais d'aller aux
assises dans la mesure où ça n'était pas
demandé par les
magistrats en tant que médecin expert je
considérais
inopportun de
venir en tant que en tant que témoin
présenté par la défense ça me paraissait
déontologiquement pas pas
[Musique]
possible Michel sabourau la défense a
prétendu que Sylvie revirigo n'avait pas
eu droit à un vrai débat contradictoire
c'est un terme que je ne comprends
pas c'est qui a choisi le silence elle
ne va pas prendre la parole elle répond
par monosyllab encore une fois mais il
fallait que Sylvie roveregoo parle et je
suis de ceux qui regrettent qu'elle ne
l'ai pas fait à cette condition là vous
auriez pu être moins dur oui oui me
semble-t-il quelle peine demandez-vous
lors de votre réquisitoire il y avait un
meurtre avec préméditation et il y avait
aussi cette atteinte à la dignité d'un
corps donc je n'ai je n'ai pas eu le
sentiment de pouvoir descendre dans
l'échelle des peines et j'ai donc requis
la réclusion criminelle à
perpétuité après 2 he de délibérer
sylvie revirego est condamné à la
réclusion criminelle à perpétuité avec
une peine de sûreté de 15
ans une décision attendue avec
appréhension par Cyril Gendron le fils
de
Françoise je l'avais lui avais fait la
leçon en disant vous ne brancherez pas
quel que soit verdict et quand le
verdict tombe il se serait bien levé
pour hurler sa joie et je l' je l'ai
cramponné physiquement pour qu'il ne
bouge pas et je le revois encore il y
avait des caméras de télévision qui
l'attendaient dans le couloir et je le
revois devant ses
caméras dire la même phrase en boucle je
suis content je suis content je suis
content je suis content que je vais pas
avoir la possibilité de faire ce que
j'aurait fait si
euh si la justice avait pas avait pas
fait son
travail comme elle l'a fait ce soir je
suis content très
[Musique]
content je me disais peut-être que 10
ans peut-être je savais très bien
qu'elle sortirait pas
[Musique]
libre maîre lisoncose ce verdicte le
moment où il tombe j'imagine que vous
vous en souvenez
tout à
fait vous sa fait rien que la réponse
aux questions au deux premières
questions montrait que
oui à la
culpabilité non aux circonstances
atténuantes ce dossier-là a été
certainement le dossier de maître Lison
CROSE elle l' traité tellement de façon
passionnelle qu'elle a peut-être oublié
de garder la distance par rapport à son
dossier la justice ne répond à aucune
des questions importantes dans cette
affaire c'est tout on sait simplement
que Sylvie revirego a tué d'une façon
atroce celle qui avait été son ami
est-ce que ce procès aurait dû être le
procès des médicaments toute la question
c'est le bon usage du médicament c'est
pas le médicament il chaque médicament
quel qu'il soit peut avoir des effets
irable s'il est mal
utilisé mal et mal prescrit en amont
donc c'est pas le procès c'est le procès
du médicament c'est le procès de l'usage
du médicament en
1991 il est impossible de faire appel du
verdict d'une cour d'assise la
condamnation de Sylvie reviregoo est
donc
[Musique]
définitive
aujourd'hui cette affaire divise encore
il existe toujours de camp les partisan
de la thèse de la psychose
médicamenteuse et ceux qui n'y croi
pas durant sa détention Sylvie revegoo
s'est confié à un journaliste de La
Nouvelle République pour elle la
question reste
entière j'ai une vie
avant j'ai divorcé j'ai eu cette
fracture avec
Mo j'aimerais que les gens se reposition
et se reconditionn dire mais qu'est-ce
qui s'est passé de juillet à
décembreil des médic prière ordnance
juillet et
cétaitchaînement ça la
[Musique]
question pendant 10 ans syv R a tout
fait pour obtenir un second
procès elle commence par saisir la Cour
de cassation la plus haute juridiction
française mais pour que la Cour de
cassation invalide un jugement il faut
qu'une violation de la loi ou un vice de
procédure soit
avéré maître Lison CROSE ce pourvoir en
cassation c'est votre dernier espoir
écoutez je je pense aussi à la Cour
européenne des droits de l'homme et
comme il faut passer par la case Cour de
cassation c'est-à-dire avoir épuisé les
voies de recours avant de saisir la Cour
européenne des droits de l'homme bon ben
je passe par la Cour de
cassation sans surprise la Cour de
Cassation considère que la procédure a
été respectée le pourvoi est rejeté il
n'y a donc pas lieu de rejuger cette
affaire un an plus tard vous décidez
d'écrire un livre sur cette affaire qui
s'appelle cherche justice désespérément
pourquoi parce que je suis en colère
parce
que en tant que qu'avocate
j'accepte difficilement l'injustice et
donc qu'est-ce qui reste à un avocat bah
il reste
l'écriture les médias faire savoir que
ça c'est pas bien passé est-ce que c'est
le point final à ce combat judiciaire
non du tout
[Musique]
Catherine Lison CROSE poursuit son
combat et saisit la Cour européenne des
droits de
l'homme une juridiction internationale
devant laquelle elle entend poursuivre
l'État
français motif Sylvie revirego n'a pas
eu un procès
équitable vous y croyez vraiment que la
France peut être condamnée et que Sylvie
revirg peut avoir un autre procès alors
il y a très peu de cas où la
CEDH donne raison à des plaignants si
vous voulez hein en tout cas la CEDH a
estimé qu'il avait pas eu de rupture de
que que l'égalité des armes avait bien
été respecté sans doute elle l'a pas
écrit comme ça si vous voulez mais elle
a rendu une décision en quelques lignes
où notre recours a été rejeté voilà en
tout cas bon après la CEDH il y a plus
rien mais j'avais un autre faer au
feu Catherine lisoncose dépose une
nouvelle plainte cette fois contre le
généraliste qui a prescrit les
médicaments à sa cliente sa stratégie
faire reconnaître la culpabilité du
médecin et donc faire admettre que la
responsabilité du crime est
partagé là encore la justice abandonne
les poursuites faute de charges
[Musique]
suffisantes reste alors une solution le
recoursant révision Michel sabouro
est-ce que sa demande de révision ça
vous surprend cette démarche m'a un peu
étonné il faut rappeler que la révision
c'est des faits nouveaux rien n'était
nouveau le débat avait eu lieu y compris
sur une éventuelle intoxication
médicamenteuse et ben l'élément nouveau
c'était un rapport d'expertise disant
que madame reviregoo est atteinte d'une
tyyrotoxicose
grave qui a induit cet état
d'agressivité extrême chez elle et
provoquer le passage à
l'acte je crois que c'était un élément
nouveau par rapport à ce qu'il avait
dans le dossier antérieurement sauf que
la chambre de révision de la Cour de
cassation me dit mais non ce n'est pas
un élément nouveau puisque cette
question des conséquence des médicaments
a été abordé devant la Cour d'assise
d'indrloire en
1991 voilà donc on s'arrête
[Musique]
là la condamnation de Sylvie revieriegoo
est
maintenue cette affaire aurait pu
aiguiser la prudence des magistrats à
l'égard des expertises quitte à prendre
le temps d'en demander davantage mais
aujourd'hui la question reste toujours
aussi compliquée
il y a un problème de la qualité de
l'expertise psychiatrique au
pénal parce qu'elle est mal rémunérée
parce qu'elle se fait dans des
conditions détestables pour les médecins
et parce que il y a des des
professionnels de l'expertise qui
enchaînent des expertises tout au long
de la semaine et qui font des
copi-collés même probablement d'une
expertise sur l'autre et ce que je dis
là
est bien connu des magistrats et
malheureusement jusqu'ici personne
n'arrive à se décideré à faire quelque
chose en revanche en ce qui concerne les
médicaments l'action s'organise quelques
mois après la condamnation de Sylvie
revirego une association voit le
jour un homme George alexandreber prend
la tête de l'Association d'aide victime
des accidents de
[Musique]
médicaments George Alexandre Himbert
pourquoi avez-vous créé cette
association alors j'ai créé cette
association en
1992 suite au décès de mon fils qui
s'est suicidé un suicide favorisé à dire
d'experts ce sont les experts qui l'ont
dit par des des tranquillisants mon fils
était dépressif le médecin est passé il
lui a fait une légère injection de
valium et à la suite de cela il a et il
a fait une crise de démence on va
appeler ça comme ça et il a voulu tuer
sa fiancée qui était présente et il
s'est tué lui qu c'était voilà quel est
le but de cette association je me suis
aperçu qu'autour de moi ben j'étais pas
le seul des personnes qui étaient très
proches ben il aurait été arrivé la même
chose au début donc c'était
principalement les suicides et ensuite
il y a des homicides des qui sont venus
euh apporter des dossiers des
témoignages c'est des c'est des produits
euh qui qui favorise un nombre de
passages à l'acte immense mais c'est
tellement gros que personne n'y fait
vraiment attention finalement quelle
conséquence a eu l'affaire Sylvie revir
yegoo alors pour Sylvie reviregoo c'est
vrai qu'il y a eu une mesure qui a été
prise une mesure ridicule puisque le
lixancia 40 on l'a supprimé et on a
accepté le lixancia 20 ce qui fait qu'on
prend deux comprimés de l'ixancia 20 ça
fait un comprimé de l'ixancia 40 mais il
faut savoir qu'en 1987 les professeurs
de pharmacologie avaient demandé le
retrait de ses produits au ministre de
la de la santé en
1987 30 ans plus tard ces médicaments
potentiellement dangereux sont toujours
sur le
marché est-ce qu'aujourd'hui avec le
recul la justice prend plus en compte
l'influence des médicaments dans ce
genre d'affaire dans notre pays non je
crois que je crois pouvoir dire que non
alors moi en tant qu'enseignant de
psychiatrie je porte ma part de
responsabilité sur le fait que
probablement les médecins ne sont pas
assez sensibilisés à cette réalité je
crois dans d'autres pays le sont
davantage aux États-Unis il y a des des
situations où on a imputé des des
accidents ou des drames à des m à des
substances psychoactives y compris
médicamenteuses ce qui est beaucoup plus
difficile en France ça a été beaucoup
plus rare
[Musique]
parmi ces rares affaires le cas Isabelle
Servier l'ironie du sort a voulu que la
fille du patron des laboratoires
pharmaceutiques lui-même incriminé dans
le scandale du Médiator soit condamné en
2005 à 5 ans de prison pour le meurtre
de son mari tué à coup de hache pendant
qu'il dormait comme Sylvie revego
Isabelle Servier prenaent des
anxiolitiques
George Alexandre Himbert vous avez été
cité à la barre dans cette affaire quel
a été votre témoignage mon témoignage
apporté sur la dangerosité du du produit
qui avait été consommé par Isabelle
Servier avant de son passage à l'acte
donc il s'agissait de
l'exomil c'est du valium c'est la même
chose c'est un produit identique elle
naavait pas pris ce produit
volontairement pour faire commettre un
crime pour pour pour passer à l'acte non
c'était ordonné médicalement donc
comment est-ce que vous expliquez cette
différence de traitement entre la
perpétuité pour Sylvie revirgo et 5 ans
pour Madame Servier alors la la
différence c'est
principalement les expertise qui était
quand même beaucoup plus favorable mais
aussi la partie civile dont les enfants
qui ont été beaucoup plus favorable à
une peine plus
légère pour vous cette condamnation à
perpétuité dans l'affaire Rev c'est une
injustice
oui c'est oui c'est une injustice c'est
une
[Musique]
injustice le médecin généraliste celui
qui avait prescrit à Sylvie Revier ygo
les fameuses ordonnances a continué à
exercer jusqu'à sa retraite il est mort
en 2015 à l'âge de 84
ans Cyril Gendron le fils de Françoise
lui ne s'est jamais remis de la mort de
sa
mère je me souviens beaucoup de Cyril
jendron qui était un garçon complètement
dévasté par ce par ces faits débasté
parce qu'il était lui-même en prise à
des difficultés personnelles j'avais
même tenté de de l'aider à ce moment-là
pour ne rien vous cacher j'ai même
essayé après les débats de lui trouver
du travail bon mais Cyril jendron est
était au prise avec une terrible
solitude et une terrible colère un
terrible ressentiment je garde le
souvenir d'un garçon complètement démoli
je pense qu'il avait une fragilité en
lui-même parce qu'il n'avait pas eu une
vie familiale très épanouissante il
avait une vie difficile il avait une une
solitude considérable le le seul élément
qui allait contre sa solitude c'était sa
mère donc elle disparaî dans ces
conditions-là et et dans l'aprèsprès
j'ai le souvenir d'un garçon qui
dégringolait doucement ayant perdu tous
les le peu de repères qu'il pouvait
avoir et qui partait dans une très
mauvaise direction vous avez eu des
nouvelles de lui depuis alors non j'ai
eu des nouvelles les premières années
parce que les premières années il
continuaiit il avait pris cette habitude
de venir assez facilement au cabinet je
pense avoir essayé de l'aider dans les
quelques démêlés qu'il a pu avoir avec
la justice la justice qui a été
d'ailleurs longtemps bienveillante parce
qu'elle comprenait qu'un garçon qui
avait subi ce qu'il avait subi puisse
dérailler un peu et puis après je l'ai
plus non c jendron a été arrêté à
plusieurs reprises pour des fêtes
délinquen la dernière fois c'était en
2012 il s'est déclaré
SDF quelle tristesse quelle tristesse je
suis extrêmement attristé mais pas très
étonné de cette dérive jusqu'à un statut
d' SDF je suis pas très
étonné Sylvie revirg quant à elle a
purgé sa peine en majeur partie à la
prison pour femme de Ren
[Musique]
maître lisoncrose comment votre cliente
a-t-elle vécu sa détention au début elle
était pas somnambule mais enfin elle
était absente mais elle s'est adaptée et
et je dois dire que que ce soit
Orléan à freine à Ren sylvier Rego était
quelqu'un de bien vu céit c'était une
personne qui rendait service elle était
couturière dans son premier métier elle
faisait des costumes elle faisait des
robes et cetera même pour des
surveillantes enfin bon je veux dire que
sylvier Reviriego c'est quelqu'un qui
savait aussi
donner tu as des femmes qui arrivent qui
des femmes qui sont cassées par la vie
donc ben souvent j'ai le rôle un peu de
maman mais ça m'a portait aussi si tu
veux parce que ça peutêre aussi
compenser un petit peu l'absence de ne
pas avir mes enfants enfin tu vois
d'apporter un petit peu de chaleur mais
j'aié beaucoup de femmes sur le
[Musique]
terrain dès la fin de sa période de
sûreté en 2003 sylvie revirg a fait
valoir son droit à une demande de
libération conditionnelle à si reprises
et pour renforcer sa défense en 2008
elle fait appel à un ténor du barreau
parisien
Pierre Olivier sû vous avez rejoint la
défense de Sylvie reveriegoo quelle
impression elle vous fait cette femme
quand je la voit c'est une petite dame
bien
mise un peu démodée comme si
effectivement les 20 années de prison
qui avait passé avait constitué une
sorte de parenthèse qui avait arrêté le
temps elle travaillait donc en prison
elle écrivait
beaucoup on venait la voir elle suivait
évidemment un parcours avec des psis des
éducateurs vous imaginez bien qu'elle
était très très spécialement suivie et
regardé et elle accepé ce suivi oui oui
tout à fait tout à fait elle était très
docile c'est pour ça que tout ça est
paradoxal par rapport évidemment au fait
qu'il lui était reproché et puis aussi
elle remboursait petit à petit la
famille de la victime je crois qu'elle a
mis quelque chose comme 30000 € ce qui
était le le le total de la condamnation
c'est complètement symbolique mais elle
remplissait voyez petit à petit toutes
ces obligations les obligations qui font
qu'à un moment donné on a pu considérer
qu'elle avait payé sa dette à la
société j'ai posé beaucoup de bobo à
droite à gauche je n'oublie jamais le
fils de de Françoise même quand je pense
à Françoise si tu veux ça me ça m'obsède
aussi parce que elle m'itait pas de
mourir et c'est vrai que maintenant
j'aimerais faire passer le message
que que je ne suis pas le monstre d'il y
a 20 ans que s'il y a eu ça c'est parce
qu'il y avit une cause à effet les gens
sont pas stupide quand même les gens ne
peuvent pas rester calqués comme ça sur
le r des fait d' y a 20 ans là tu tu te
prépares une trè vie non 4e bien sûr que
j'y crois à cette liberté la vie est
courte quoi qu'il en soit
elle semble avoir des regrets semble
prendre conscience de la gravité de
l'horreur ce qu'elle a fait ah oui euh
évidemment des
regrets des
remords la recherche du pardon elle ne
s'est pas révolté du tout d'avoir été
mise en prison et pour longtemps
finalement on leura sorti de prison ça a
pas marché la première fois on a
toujours l'impression que pour ouvrir
une porte de prison c'est comme un pot
de confiture vous savez on essae une
fois deux fois trois fois et puis à un
moment donné ça va céder elle a renoncé
une demande de révision de de son procès
c'est bien qu'elle ait renoncé ça veut
dire qu'elle a
[Musique]
accepté sylvie reviregoo a quitter la
prison de reen en août 2009 après plus
de 20 ans de
détention impossible pour elle de
retourner vivre en Touren où son nom est
encore dans toutes les
mémoires
quand elle est sortie elle elle était
elle travaillait dans une association
sur Paris et je lui ai donné rendez-vous
je l'ai invité au restaurant au nom de
l'association cette petite bonne femme
toute blonde arrivé bon on voyait que
c'est une était habillée d'une petite
raye quoi ça faisait un peu toarde bon
et donc elle m'a dit ça fait 20 ans que
je n'ai pas mangé d'huîre alors je lui
je lui ai offert des des hues
et puis je lui ai remis un chèque au nom
de l'Association pour qu'elle puisse
s'en sortir un chèque très modeste
cétait aux alentours de 3 400 € je sais
plus très bien et puis depuis je ne l'ai
pas revu Pierre Olivier sûr qui est
devenu syvievigo aujourd'hui ah elle a
elle a reconstruit sa vie
elle bénéficie du droit à l'oubli sous
un autre nom est-ce qu'elle a de la
famille auprès d'elle des amis des gens
qui la soutiennent
elle a de la famille elle a des gens qui
la soutiennent et vous n'en saurez rien
de
plus 20 ans de détention pour une
condamnation à perpétuité Sylvi Revier
ygo a-t-elle payé son crime oui je crois
qu'il ne faut pas non plus aller trop
loin dans la répression et que on
considère que la moyenne si je puis dire
des réclusions criminelles à perpétuité
c'est autour de 18 20 ans donc elle a
accompli une peine un certain nombre de
conditions ont été mises à sa remise en
liberté voilà donc je ne crois pas non
plus qu'il fallait aller trop loin
encore une fois dans l'exécution de
cette peine est-ce qu'elle pourrait
recommencer un jour je ne pense pas je
ne pense pas elle n'avait pas ce profil
là elle a eu cette cette espèce de
d'irruption on peut dire criminelle
violente mais c'est un projet
heureusement unique c'est une explosion
sur quelques
jours je ne la vois pas être à nouveau
criminel c'est c'est c'est d'ailleurs
extrêmement rare non elle ne peut plus
être dangereuse ce qu'elle a vécu euh
c'est une cisure totale euh dans sa vie
qui l'a complètement dépassé et qui ne
s'explique pas rien de sa vie et c'est
ça qui est étrange dans ce dossier un
terroriste on comprend à un moment donné
il bascule euh il est pris en en charge
par des idées qui le manipulent et puis
petit à petit il y a un cheminement
criminel qui fait que rien ne se passe
en une fraction de seconde tout
s'explique par quelque chose avant ici
c'est la fraction de seconde qui décide
de tout et quand vous me demandiez si
elle
est dangereuse je vous dis non
absolument pas j'en suis absolument
intimement convaincu